[Musique]
alors jma marjane laisser là j'ai 35 ans
et je suis créatrice de la marque de
bijoux m'avait déjà bijoux alors mon
entreprise est une entreprise de
création de bijoux c'est marc mix de
bijoux pour homme et pour femme fait
main artisanalement et à la réunion je
travaille essentiellement la matière
comme le cuir qui ne m'attire nomme que
j'aime beaucoup et le métal c'est un
métal plaqué argent donc souvent c'est
de l'étain du hamac ou du letton donc
c'est des métaux de haute fantaisie donc
dans les bijoux retrouve une gamme de
boucles d'oreilles gamme de sautoirs une
gamme de bracelets pour les femmes est
également une gamme de colliers et
bracelets pour les hommes
alors j'ai décidé de concourir dans la
catégorie insertion parce qu'en fait je
sors d'un emploi en grande distribution
qui ne convenait pas vraiment et j'avais
vraiment envie de créer mon emploi avec
mes valeurs
avec un respect avec avec des choses que
j'avais envie de mettre à cuire dans mon
entreprise
alors avant de créer mon entreprise j'ai
eu un parcours professionnel de 15 ans
dans le commerce qui me sert énormément
aujourd'hui mon dernier poste était
adjointe de direction en grande
distribution pour pouvoir créer cette
entreprise me suis tourné vers la
couveuse réussite qui m'ont énormément
aidé alors le fait des chefs
d'entreprise ça m'apporte une grande
autonomie
une certaine liberté que j'aime beaucoup
on touche à divers secteurs d'activité
c'est pas juste faire des bijoux c'est
aussi être dans la com c'est aussi être
dans le e-commerce c'est une richesse
énorme alors ce qui fait que je vais
remporter le challenge des créateurs ça
serait une récompense pour l'acharnement
les efforts du travail énorme que sa
demande de créer une entreprise en tant
que femme déjà en tant que personne
seule au départ sans forcément une
énorme trésorerie donc qu'on compense
énormément par des heures de travail et
surtout cette passion qui fait que j'ai
envie de continuer ne pas lâcher
développer sa haut niveau au niveau
réunionnais et au niveau même
internationale et aussi pouvoir
développer l'entreprise en embauchant du
personnel en développement les points de
vente en développement quand le site
internet
[Musique]
bonjour bien à des prêts afin 47 ans
chef d'entreprise en sécurité
en activité c'est la sécurité
l'entreprise que j'ai créé ces unités
sécurité privée 1.0.0 signifie que je
suis toute seule sur le terrain comme
sur le papier et que je suis la seule
femme qui intervient dans le milieu de
la sécurité sur le papier je suis
formatrice dans ce milieu est reconnue
par la branche parce que je suis diplômé
et
et je suis aussi agent de sécurité j'ai
voulu conquérir dans cette catégorie
parce que j'ai créé mon propre plan et
par la suite j'ai pu
créer d'autres postes pour d'autres
personnes qui n'ont jamais été sur le
terrain j'ai créé au moins 100 emplois
dans l'activité avant de créer mon
entreprise j'étais en espace vert
après en même temps parallèle je faisais
question dans ma démarche le palois m'a
beaucoup aidé au niveau des formations
et par la suite je me suis débrouillé
tout seul
j'ai fait des plusieurs petits boulots
c'est à dire les passagers garde
d'enfants pour arriver à mettre en place
mon activité
la position de chef d'entreprise dans le
milieu de la sécurité
on reporte plus de connaissances une
richesse au niveau des agents quand j'ai
créé mon entreprise et enfin que c'était
très difficile pour moi d'intégrer le
milieu
maintenant je sais ce que je vaux et je
suis respecté par le monde de la
sécurité
ma situation aujourd'hui je trouve
qu'elle est grandiose parce que je vois
beaucoup de monde et je me vois évoluer
je vais gagner le challenge des
créateurs parce que dans ma tête
catégorie je crée environ plus d'une
centaine d'emplois et par le biais de ma
formation de formatrice j'aide les
personnes qui sont mal orientées avec
des stages ou des formations un peu
qu'ils aient conviennent
[Musique]